I'm wearing a golf shirt I have on a
golf shirt today if you're on the
YouTube you can see it I have a golf
shirt on I don't play a lot of golf
I think I could though I see men play it
you know I see sometimes I've been
invited to some of these fans here get
togethers with these fellas out there
doing golf
you know when it's everybody dresses a
little bit
it almost looks everybody dresses like
they're adults that are going to maybe
be looking for Easter eggs
you know and everybody's like trying to
be friendly and have beers and stuff but
also everybody's thinking about
maybe banging each other's wives or
making love to each other's wives
but uh but it looks fun sometimes I've
played a few games almost killed a
famous golf designer uh uh
famous golf course designer one time
what was his name die I thought his last
name was die and that's not a joke I
thought his last name was actually die